I don't know if you remember
what the article was about,
but I wrote about,
uh,
Eric Green Murray is a professor at the
political science department and he was
forced to include,
uh,
Judith Butler,
Butler.
Oh yeah,
right.
Chewed his butler.
Yeah.
Great,
great.
And,
uh,
the course is about modern
society and its and its critics.
So it's been amazing basically about
the reactionary forces and a left wing
extremist forces during the
turn of the last century.
So in the early 20th century,
late 19th century.
And then you read Butler,
um,
and actually one of the
course a and not Eric,
but,
uh,
his,
his teaching assistant interview
and she said that she
disagreed with the method.
So she agreed with the
professors that she did.
She thought that the academic
freedom was more important than,
uh,
being forced to teach
about a feminist authors,
certain gender science.
So she was actually,
uh,
on the other side.
Gender Science.
Yeah,
exactly.
Where is by no means a scientist
or even a credible academic?
As far as I'm concerned,
I think she's a straight
out idealog and um,
and the fact that anybody would be forced,
well first of all forced to include
anything on their curriculum I think is
absolutely reprehensible.
It's top down interference with academic
freedom and it's extraordinarily
dangerous because once that
precedent is established,
then you opened the door for
political interference in the like,
I like,
like organized political interference
from outside the academy and it'll
collapse very rapidly underserved.
We saw that happening in Germany and also
in the Soviet Union and like that can
happen so quickly that people can't,
can't,
it's almost impossible to believe.
Now we're in this weird situation where
the same thing seems to be happening to
a large degree within the academy itself.
And so,
and what to do about that
is by no means obvious but,
but I don't think that allowing external
control of any sort over the contents
of the courses the professor
teach professors teach is,
it's a very,
very bad idea.
We,
uh,
they have a rule,
rule of thumb,
they call it,
but it's basically,
it's much more a rule,
the rule of thumb.
But at least 40% of all the
literature has to be written by women.
So if you are unbelievable,
if you're holding a course,
for example,
about Portland Society,
then it's critic critics with a lot of
primary literature from the turn of the
century,
then you run into a problem
because women weren't,
uh,
so,
there weren't a lot of women
were authors back then.
You,
oh,
he's so unbelievably,
yeah.
I would say resentful.
I really think that's the
fundamental issue here,
to push a doctor resentful and
uninformed to push a doctrine like that.
Yeah.